I just got a report that Ronnie Ronnie
Mund has brand new eyeglasses according
to M their Howard Stern sunglasses John
Blitz said they were sexy I want to see
let's see Ronnie with his soft launch
for his new look the office is a buzz
this oh my God oh my God I I didn't know
it was such big news you know oh my God
the the whole office is buzzing about
your glasses wow yeah it's a big buz no
it's split having a big buzz I don't
feel they're Howard sternik I wanted us
all to be a buzz not at all now come on
don't say not at all Robin you feel the
Howard Stern like well look first you've
got the double thing in the middle which
is just like you it's going to make him
nuts if you say that a little off okay
Robin yeah whatever and the the arms are
slightly thinner than yours uh tent
almost as deep as yours but a different
I always I always have tent okay always
yeah this is a dark or t John what uh
information John blit what information
do you have about Ronnie's new glasses
what have you learned has no information
like my glasses are tinted yours are
yours are sunglasses they're
aggressively tinted aggressively tinted
no they're tinted there's I can't see
your eyes Ronnie good that's the whole
idea okay well that's called
not sunglasses I could see perfectly at
night I could see perfectly in the light
they're not that dark they just look
that way I think you're bumping into
things at night when I think you're
[__] up an idiot okay you can possibly
wear those glasses at night r i I just I
went out Saturday Friday and Saturday
night I was out with them driving
everything they're fine with a white did
you carry a white stick yeah yeah yeah
white stick yeah I don't think you
should drive it at night with those
glasses honestly I I don't I'm I'm not
making a joke I think that's a dangerous
thing there's no problem with them
believe me you should carry a second set
of glasses and have those for driving
those are too dark that's too dark for
driving at night no it's not Ronnie
you're not even facing the right way
now yeah okay but's claiming that
tomorrow Ronnie's planning to have long
curly black
hair yeah I bought I bought a wig to go
with the glasses I I don't want to pile
on but Ronnie those go ahead pile on
[__] when you bought them you didn't
go oh these are Howard glasses and I'm
for this no not at all dude okay I he
doesn't realize it my but he idolizes me
Ronnie does yeah dude look at your
glasses that you're [__] wearing
they're nothing like this what are you
talking about blit go [__] yourself okay
well I didn't do anything I'm
complimenting them no the you
interrupted the mic check this morning
in the middle of the mic check you
interrup Ed with your big mouth did you
get new glasses I said nice glasses I
was blown away by the new look no that's
not what you said I said nice glasses
are those new are those new okay yeah
are they new [__] big well Ronnie your
new glasses are a showstopper I will say
there was an insta Poole in our office
91% of the staff think that Ronnie is
wearing full-on sunglasses that they are
not tinted they're more sunglass like
I'm among the 91% I I do believe that
you feel what you feel and I know what I
see okay right I see perfectly in the
daylight I see perfectly at night by the
way Ronnie puppet now has new glasses
yeah call call me Maverick
yeah no those are sunglasses these
glasses are perfectly safe to drive on
the suwit I still see my eyes through
the [__] glasses so don't tell me
these are [__] sunglasses okay yeah
they can see a little hint it's like
Helen Keller's glasses yeah okay Helen
Keller
right he looks like a an elderly sort of
Terminator you know what I mean he looks
like the arold Schwarz character yeah
I'll be
back I'm already back AA Lista
dildo